are you ready to speak in English the
whole time yes hi guys today i'm here
with Clara
who is a Swedish longer if you don't
know you need to check out her stuff
because she's hilarious and how do you
know you talk about periods all the time
which is what we're talking about
oh damn not all the time but I like to
I've never known a girl to embrace
period more than this woman to my right
oh okay
so how many videos would you say that
you've made that pertain to menstruation
I counted the other day and I have done
I think I've done in total like a
hundred and ten oh no no no 110 120
videos in total on my channel okay and
eight of them eight of them yes okay I
was gonna say how and nipsey knew a
conversation about menstruation for a
hundred and twenty videos creative yeah
so just never leaves would you call
yourself an expert mmm
okay would you call yourself like an
instructor or a teacher or just a no
just uh a motivator a motivator of a
menstruation motivator Wow I'm super
cute right yeah I'm sad on my cookin
bake we shot a video over on her channel
where her audience asked us questions
about our periods and we answered very
candidly so it'll go check that out and
then it's kind of inspired me to want to
talk to you guys about it because on
that video I realized that my mom never
really talked to me about this time
into the lady's life what's a great
piece of advice that either you've come
up with on your own or that someone has
given you I think that many girls think
that masturbation and period is
something really bad and they don't look
forward to it and neither do I I don't
like my period even though I talk about
it a lot
I don't it's horrible yep it's sticky
and it's much anyway to be a little more
positive maybe you could think that yay
my body works as it should be working I
say every month I'm not pregnant
yeah my body works and yay I'm not
pregnant it's nothing I'm having a baby
and if you wanting to have a baby
then when your period doesn't come then
you can say yay I'm having a baby
Sweden gets it I just wish that there
was some equivalent that men could have
once a month that would just say she ate
me from going through this week blowing
things kicking the bills right like if
they just had like some sparkles fall
out of their scrotums one I would be
jealous okay well yeah that's probably
really great to someone right to God
have them reevaluate and Mike we're in
Hertz as well yeah make sure it hurts
make sure that it's like uncomfortable
make sure it ruins some of his clothes
make sure that this dad is really
uncomfortable telling it that this is
gonna happened to him when he gets
teenager just really really make it hurt
my advice is always have medicine like
pain medicine around especially her
cramps I kind of they're so travel-size
like ad bills and things like that that
I kind of always keep in like a
of mine I I was in school and one of my
friends had bought some candy and I
wasn't my favorite and she she offered
me because she she knew that I was so
emotionally unique you doubt that he'll
so I had this piece of chocolate and I
started crying and I didn't have any
pills to eat
bring your pills kidding chuckling
crying it was the most delicious piece
of chocolate I have ever even I've never
done cried yes it's so good another time
I listen to a Polly Rock Anthem by LMFAO
and I cried that it's a really good song
the lyrics were so profound and moving
maybe and it's a good beat so do you
have any other go to things that you
would suggest for someone that is
dealing with this terrible terrible
affliction that we all have embrace it
feel no pain love the pain as someone
said in a Disney movie I thought and I
don't agree but I feel like you heard
he's watching a workout DVD I know it
was what's a cool frozen Cinderella home
alone it was about robots make a robot
know the future no it was I
you may sit animated I bet you're an
advanced movie I Robot is the best and I
broke was it will never know just like
we'll never know why we have periods and
go over to Claire Jenna watch the videos
I've made over there really hey we
really revealed a lot about ourselves
feel like I am by association and have
already started my period because of all
let's talk would you like to say
something in Swedish hey that it off
school hey a larger-scale fans that's so
racist